oktoberfest another vibe has returned to
the hofbrau house las vegas for the 17th
year and our own mercedes martinez is
there live to tell us about the
festivities that every no she's got a
beer festivities that everyone can enjoy
for the next few weeks mercedes take it
away
pros guys it is oktoberfest here at
hofra house las vegas we are celebrating
through the end of october i'm joined by
patrick here patrick barrett he is the
general manager of hop raw house las
vegas and this is the only official
opera house celebration for oktoberfest
this year true sadly this year because
of the pandemic in germany oktoberfest
was cancelled so this one the only
places in the world you can celebrate
authentic oktoberfest now i learned a
phrase um if you want to order one of
these you can say ein ghost beer that
means one large beer and then when you
cheers you say pros
and then there's a song that you sing
when you're celebrating how does that go
i i need to learn this the ziggy zaggy
yes ziggy zaggy ziggy zaggy
okay so these are the things you need to
learn if you're coming to oktoberfest
here at hofbrauhaus las vegas we have
keg tappings going on celebrity keg
tappings tell us a little bit about that
so every friday and saturday night as we
celebrate oktoberfest we have celebrity
keg tappers come in and they tap our
ceremonial keg and we start the the fun
this is uh this is very intricate so
this goes in there and then you just how
do you how do you you're gonna
you need to know this because you're
gonna you're going to be doing this and
you're gonna pound that in and the keg
will tap and the beer will flow the beer
will flow yes so this weekend friday
night tonight we have frankie mourinho
who's going to be one of the celebrity
tappers tomorrow night is murray sacha
and on october 30th who's going to be
tackling the gag saving the best for
last yes i will be here then but you can
come party all the way through the end
of october it is so much fun and uh of
course you can't forget the beer you're
not going to get your domestic beers
here you're going to get your good hoff
brow house what is this one here this is
the original this is our lager
we serve the lager we have our dunkle
which is our dark beer and then we have
our heffenweisen which is our wheat beer
all right so prost everyone coming up
we're going to take you behind the
scenes with some of the amazing german
food that you can get here in the
meantime i'll send it back to you
chug chug
chug drink drink
[Applause]
drink all right it's getting crazy in
here guys thank you so much for saying
that was so much fun we will check back
when with her in the 4pm hour yeah later
in the hours
she'll have that beer done by then yeah
right opera house las vegas as mercedes
said we got frankie mourinho tonight
mark schnuck is coming up as you can see
gordy brown and then mercedes will be
tapping the keg on saturday october 30th
i forgot we were an hour what's it yeah
it's an hour show
there we go all right now